chivo wallet everyone knows that back in
june the president of el salvador
announced that they were going to pass
legislation to make bitcoin legal tender
within the country not only did they
pass that legislation they have gone
further and farther than anyone thought
they would be so they have set up mining
facilities uh inside or using volcano
energy they also have launched the chivo
wallet they have launched a network of
chivo atms as well in the last four
months we have all of the different
things that el salvador has accomplished
one they adopted bitcoin as legal tender
two they distributed 30 of bitcoin to
about half of the country's citizens
they installed 200 bitcoin atms in the
country they purchased 700 bitcoin for
the national reserve that is about 33
million dollars today they're up on that
bitcoin purchase they also began mining
bitcoin through volcanoes that is 100
renewable power well the president of el
salvador just like francis suarez in
miami is acting as the the ceo of the
city
buchelli is acting as the ceo of el
salvador he keeps tweeting what their
progress is so over the weekend he
tweeted three million salvadorians are
now using the chivo wallet
bitcoin now three million people in a
country like america doesn't sound like
a huge number we've got 330 million
americans give or take but in el
salvador there's only about 6.5 million
people total that's right in el salvador
50 of the country approximately is
already using the chivo bitcoin wallet
which means in less than 30 days they
have reaped massive penetration now they
are paying 30 to anyone who downloads
the app and begins to use it so
obviously when you have an economic
incentive like that a lot of people are
going to go download it they're going to
get their 30 worth of bitcoin the big
question is going to be 6 12 18 24
months from now how many people are
still using it but the reports that we
are seeing including the president
tweeting literally the dashboard of the
analytics to the app
at one point
suggest that these are not just
downloads these are actually active
users now they're still only active
within the last month because it's only
a month old so we'll see how it plays
out but absolutely incredible imagine
the united states government creating a
piece of technology launching it and
getting approximately 50 of the
population to download it within 30 days
it's not that easy now on top of this
what becomes very fascinating to me is
the virality of money is likely to take
hold and so if you are in el salvador
and those three million people they are
going to transact with each other
they're going to transact with merchants
but they also are going to transact with
people outside of the country and so i
would not be surprised if we saw the
adoption of this
app continue to uh kind of accelerate
what do we think about el salvador
already being this far ahead in four
months legal tender 200 bitcoin atm 700
bitcoin in the nation's reserves they're
also mining with volcanoes now they've
got about 50 of the population using
this app i think it's crazy when you
think about uh the app launched less
than a month ago right so like they did
all the other things in the past over
the last four months like you mentioned
but the chivo wallet had only uh only
launched 26 27 days ago or something
like that right so uh over the last
month they've got they've onboarded
three million people which as you said
the other day if they were a technology
company here in the us they wouldn't be
able to raise or they'd be able to raise
money you know within a day so
i think when you look at it kind of the
ability and how quickly they've been
able to move and the size and skill that
they've been able to onboard people it's
super impressive and they're doing it uh
for a relatively low cost like 30
dollars potentially to acquire customers
really not that much when you think
about it from an exchange or a wallet
standpoint so i think it's obviously
cool that he is updating kind of the
public through twitter and doing all
these things that we mentioned
previously but just the results are
really good right within 26 27 days to
onboard three million people about half
the country uh is obviously great and
then i think when you look at it from a
price standpoint right like we've been
kind of in this the price actually
declined i think when they first
launched it was 50 52 000 uh per bitcoin
it went all the way down to 40 or 41 uh
and now we're hovering kind of in that
47.48 range but i think if you see the
price appreciate rapidly you know 55 60
65 and we test those new all-time highs
test the new all-time high i think we'll
see that even go quicker right we'll see
more people adopt the app they'll say
hey what is this bitcoin you're getting
30 worth of it it's appreciating in
price all this stuff and i think what
we'll see is it'll go way over 50 of the
population agreed john what do you think
super impressive the way he's been able
to do this in such a short time frame
it's interesting that not only when the
price went down he held but he also
bought more right so he was kind of
doubling down on his investment the one
thing is the 30 the 30 may not be a lot
per customer but it's 90 million dollars
right so it's not a small chunk of
change that he's doing to onboard this
i'm really interested to see next month
if he still tweets the monthly users
because that will be a big thing right
everyone use it you get your 30 what do
you do from there do you use it again uh
and the second month i think is gonna be
really key because
you know you get a really big influx of
customers in the first month it's hard
to retain and what will those retention
rates be